new details in the case Bianca Holman
reports metro police say the father of
the 22 month old Roy Jones was most
likely racing his mother attempting to
pass one another when Lauren pressure
crashed along Grand part in Lake Mead
Boulevard both were expect to do the in
court today but neither showed due to
medical reasons which has not been
disclosed
Lauren precious attorney Daniel Hill
appeared on her behalf
she's being held on $50,000 bail the 23
year old is accused of driving impaired
reckless driving and child abuse neglect
precious preliminary hearing is
scheduled for July 30th Royces father
Cameron Hubbard Jones is charged with
reckless driving during the court
hearing the judge said Hubbard Jones has
one prior misdemeanor and one felony
child
so the potential penalty here is quite
severe at this early stage of proceeding
sustained is the pilot in detention
without bail based on all information
holders who arrest me violate the terms
of his parole
however Jones is expected back in court
on Monday there's a growing memorial for
voice at the crash scene people have
left toys balloons and candles there
will be a memorial for the child tonight
at 8 p.m. at buckskin Basin Park that's
located in the northwest Valley
reporting from downtown Bianca Holman 8
news now